the U.S energy Department says that
after seeing new intelligence concerning
the origins of kovid it now concludes
the global pandemic most likely was
caused by a lab leak in China That's
according to the Wall Street Journal
joining us now former Director of
National Intelligence John Radcliffe
great to have you here sir before we get
your reaction I would just like to play
for everybody this is Biden's National
Security advisor on this topic yesterday
President Biden specifically requested
that the National Labs which are part of
the Department of energy be brought into
this assessment because he wants to put
every tool at use to be able to figure
out what happened here and if we gain
any further Insider information we will
share it with Congress and we will share
it with the American people
what's your reaction to this as it came
out yesterday morning
well I'm not surprised in fact I
predicted that there would be a shift
among all of the intelligence agencies
because you know Dana frankly the idea
that the uh covid-19 uh virus was of
natural Origins has always been at odds
with our intelligence I mean from my
first day as the as the Director and
looking at that that was very clear and
I think what you've seen is uh you know
back in April of 2020 uh the
intelligence Community is unanimously
agreed with the scientific community
that this was of natural Origins it has
now shifted and you see more and more
agencies
coming to the conclusion with some
degree of confidence in their assessment
that uh that this was the result of a
lab leak and I think over time Dana what
you're going to find is that the entire
intelligence Community will reach that
assessment because our intelligence very
clearly supports that assessment but but
if the department of energy is saying
that so would they not know
well it what I didn't understand about
uh Jake Sullivan's comments is the the
department of energy has been involved
like other their intelligence components
have been involved with this from the
beginning and
um you know not to get too technical on
this bill but from the beginning uh it
has been clear that scientists have not
been able to explain why there's
something called a fern cleavage site
within the genetic makeup of the
covid-19 virus and and that's why you
had these scientists privately in emails
conceding I don't know how this occurs
in nature that is something that happens
when scientists insert a snippet of
genetic material into manipulated
viruses and so from the beginning there
has never been an environmental source
for covid-19 there has never been an
intermediary host identified and why
that's important for for your for your
viewers is with the original SARS virus
and with the original with the with the
MERS virus those intermediary hosts were
found within in a matter of months we're
now three and a half years from the
origins of covid-19 and no intermediary
host nothing tying this to the natural
world has been found which is why you
see all of these scientists and now
intelligence agencies backing away from
prior assessments backing away from the
idea that there was possibility of
natural origin and moving to the
assessment that this was the result of a
lab leak can I about the timing of this
coming out yesterday morning and I'm not
I usually think things are very much
more of a coincidence than any sort of
strategy but I do want to ask you know
last week we knew that the
administration was telling us that China
was about to sell weapons to Russia in
order to use against Ukraine and then
this comes out on Sunday morning but it
feels to me like they would have had
this information for a long time so are
you suspicious of the timing of the
information getting out
uh I had the same uh initial thoughts
that you did Dana I don't think that
this is a coincidence I I do hope that
this is part of a strategy to hold China
in check that would be a good sign that
the Biden Administration is is thinking
about these things but you know to the
larger picture I also wish that this
acknowledgment and assessment across the
board the China
notwithstanding in fact I understand
that the geopolitical ramifications of
of of concluding that China is
responsible for the deaths of now tens
of millions of people more than a
million Americans from a lab accident
that happened in Wuhan are are
significant but I do think in the scope
of things the American people deserve to
have a truthful assessment and our
Intelligence on this is clear I said it
years ago that this shift would take
place and it will continue where
eventually we'll get to the point where
everyone is conceding that this was a
result of a labeling well I mean
Sullivan said the National Labs are part
of the Department of energy doe
Department of energy is what said this
came from Wuhan speaking of Wuhan New
York Post headline of the day it had to
be it had to be woo sing it singing not
now come on John Radcliffe thank you sir
come on back soon okay thank you for
your time today I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis